four days before he became a sex killer
PC Wayne cousins indecently exposed
himself that this drive-through
restaurant
staff victims alerted the Metropolitan
Police his own Force the next day they
provided security camera footage and the
driver's payment details
CCTV showed the car involved and Wayne
cousins was identified as its registered
owner it even used his own credit card
to pay for food but the Met said that by
that stage it hadn't established that
cousins was a serving police officer
soon after cousins used his warrant card
and handcuffs to make a false arrest
he abducted marketing executive Sarah
everard raped her and killed her
the police Constable who allegedly
bungled the flashing investigation and
lied about it has been charged with
gross misconduct but he retired last
year and will escape punishment
any investigators who look at flashing
and then go on to look at sexual
offenses know that flashing always leads
to more and more serious offenses in the
past it has been discounted has been a
bit of a you know a nuisance almost and
anti-social but nothing serious but
studies Academia have also shown that
that always leads to a greater offense
in Dover Kent a Second Officer a
sergeant is to be disciplined over
another indecent exposure in 2015 again
a car registered to cousins no action
was taken
cousins is already serving whole life
for Miss everard's Murder he'll be
sentenced for indecent exposure next
month
Martin brunt Sky News